Also präzise ist, war jetzt die Situation, dass das Unternehmen aufgrund ihrer Eigeninteressenlage, den also dann am Sonntag spontan eingeladen hat, doch zu ihnen zu kommen. Der hat sich in Taxi gesetzt und ist ein paar 100 Kilometer hier nach Berlin gefahren, um hier am Nachmittag einzutreffen. Interessanterweise, wie gesagt, die Polizei wartete schon, aber offenbar im Nebenzimmer, stellte sich dann aber heraus, eine Straftat lag nicht vor, die Polizei ist wieder abgerückt. Und dann beginnen Gespräche darüber, was dann da eigentlich passiert wäre und unter welchen Bedingungen man jetzt irgendwie weiter hier daran arbeiten würde, diese Sicherheitslücken zu beheben. Ich war bei den Gesprächen nicht dabei. Ich kann jetzt hier nur ein bisschen zitieren aus der Beteiligung seines Anwalts. Deswegen muss ich mich jetzt ein bisschen mit so Floskeln behelfen. Klar ist, im Laufe des Gesprächs ging es wohl irgendwann auch um eine mögliche finanzielle Vergütung für den Schaden, den er durch das Offenbaren dieser Sicherheitslücke dem Unternehmen gegenüber abwenden könnte. Das Unternehmen hat so ist eine der Darstellungen von sich aus angeboten, ihm einen Betrag von irgendwie 20.000 Euro oder irgendetwas zu zahlen. Und wenn die Berichterstattung, die ich erfolgen habe, so korrekt ist, dann ist eben der Moment, wo er gesagt hat, naja klar, also wenn ihr mir irgendwie einen bestimmten Betrag zahlt, dann will ich euch schon helfen. Genau dieses quasi Eingehen auf das Angebot wurde dann gleich zack ihm als Erpressung ausgelegt. Damit war eben das gegeben, was man eigentlich brauchte, nämlich eine Straftat. Und nun mag das so oder so gelaufen sein, man muss hier sehen, der Typ war 20 Jahre alt. Die Leute, mit denen er zu tun hatte, waren studierte Volljuristen bzw. Geschäftsführer. Das heißt, er war ganz klar in unterlegenen Situationen im Bezug auf seine Fähigkeit, vielleicht auch hier einzuschätzen, mit welchen Interessen, mit welchen Kräften er sich hier eingelassen hatte. Und das ist natürlich eine ganz ungute Situation, die wir als CCC eigentlich immer versucht haben zu verhindern, dadurch, dass wir auch gesagt haben, wir sind auch gerne so ein Ding dazwischen, ein Vermittler, weil wir eben genug Erfahrung damit haben, was passiert, wenn irgendwelche Hacker an Systembetreiber geraten, die so ihre ganz eigenen Vorstellungen davon haben, wie man Sicherheit durchsetzt.
Und wir sollten dazu sagen, auch wenn es so aussieht, nach der Geschichte, mit der wir eingeleitet haben, als wenn man da immer mal gut und gerne fünfstellige Beträge raustragen kann, das ist nicht der Normalfall. Also es gibt noch eine Geschichte, die Andy noch erzählen wollte mit Jugendforsch, das kann man noch mal einbringen, aber der Normalfall ist eben, dass man da kein Geld raustragen kann. Das muss man ganz klar sagen. Und deswegen überlegt euch das vorher, lasst euch da nicht von eurer Gier leiten, sondern kommt lieber direkt zu uns. Und wir haben das dann schon mal gemacht und können euch helfen, da lebend und ohne Schulden wieder rauszukommen.
Seid ihr sozusagen die Einzigen, die das machen können? Oder geht es darum, irgendwie geartete Vertrauenspersonen zu finden?
Es kommt natürlich immer auf die Art der Sicherheitsdruck an, die man entdeckt. Es gab in den 80er Jahren mal einen, der hat bei Jugendforscht seine kleine Bastelarbeit eingereicht. Das war eine Telefonkarte, die nie leer wurde. Und die Jury dieses Jugendforscht-Institutionen, die haben sich das angehört und gesagt, das entspricht nicht ganz unseren Ausstellungsbedingungen. Aber irgendwie ist es ja schon eine ausgetüftete Baselai. Der ist mit einem Beratervertrag der Telekom wohl aus der Sache rausgekommen. Aber natürlich wird in so einem Kontext als allererste Mal eine Verschwiegenheitsverklärung unterschrieben. Das heißt, davon gerät niemals die Öffentlichkeit. Und ich weiß, dass ich das auch nur von merkwürdigen Gerüchten für deren Gewähr nicht haften kann. Aber das sind die Geschichten, die das Leben da schreibt. Bloß diese Sache mit der Erpressung jetzt als anderes extrem, das gibt es natürlich auch in den Bereichen bei Banken beispielsweise. Wenn man da irgendwie zu sehr in die Daten gerät, dann haben die einfach ein vitales Interesse daran, dass die Nummer nicht an die Öffentlichkeit gerät und dass derjenige, der was darüber erzählen könnte, mit Journalisten reden könnte, dass der im Service-Zeit mal sofort weg verhaftet wird.
Erpressung ist die Standardmethode, das muss man sagen. Es ist kein Einzelfall, dass dieser Mann bei VZnet jetzt wegen Erpressung rangeholt wurde. Das ist der Normalfall. Genau wie Polizisten nach Demos immer sagen, man habe sie angegriffen. Wenn ein Hacker kommt, wird immer Erpressung gesagt, weil man das Gegenteil auch nicht beweisen kann. Dann heißt es eben, wir haben hier Geschäfte zu verlieren und der wollte unser Geld haben. Und dann guckt man sich den langhaarigen Hacker an. Der sieht vielleicht auch noch ein bisschen unsozialisiert aus. Und dann ist für den durchschnittlichen Polizeibeamten und Richter und Staatsanwalt die Sache klar.
Dem, in dem ich jetzt erst mal eine klare Warnung habe, so direkter Kontakt ist nicht so geil. Wie macht man es jetzt?
Genau, also die beste Variante ist, dass man sich einen Anwalt nimmt. Denn der Anwalt kann im Zweifelsfall ein Zeugnisverweigerungsrecht geltend machen. Das heißt, wenn jetzt jemand mit seinem Kumpel dahingeht, so ein Fall hat es auch schon gegeben vor kurzer Zeit, da hat jemand mit der Deutschen Bank geredet und hat seinen Kumpel mitgenommen. Der Kumpel hat dann später gegen ihn ausgesagt. Und das muss man jetzt gar nicht mal sagen. Der Kumpel war böse, das weiß ich in dem Fall gar nicht. Aber man kann sich das mal psychologisch überlegen, wenn die Polizei dann auf den Kumpel niederkommt und dem erzählt, hier, pass mal auf Junge, du kommst gleich wegen Komplizenschaft in den Knast, denn du hast ja auch im Grunde mit erpresst. Natürlich sagt er dann aus. Also bringt nicht euren Kumpel mit, sondern nehmt jemanden, der im Zweifelsfall Zeugnisverweigerungsrecht hat, und das ist entweder ein Anwalt oder Presse. Oder ihr kommt zu uns und wir machen das dann mit dem Anwalt und der Anwalt fragt uns als Experte, dann haben wir auch ein Zeugnisverweigerungsrecht. Aber einfach nur einen Kumpel mitnehmen ist keine Lösung.
Ja, also die Datenschutzbeauftragten sind mittlerweile auch so weit, dass sie solche Vermittlung machen. Natürlich vor allem bei Fällen, wo personenbezogene Daten in irgendeiner Form im Spiel sind. Das ist allerdings, man muss es sagen, es gibt sozusagen ein bisschen Missverständnis um den Begriff Datenschutz, weil Datenschutz ist ja zunächst mal die gesetzliche Regelung der informationellen Selbstbestimmung, unter welchen Voraussetzungen also personenbezogene Daten verarbeitet werden und nicht das, was wir vielleicht unter Datenschutz verstehen, nämlich technischer Datenschutz, also wie technisch Daten geschützt werden. Es gibt aber mittlerweile auch bei den Datenschutzbeauftragten die Erkenntnis, dass man das eigentlich nicht so ganz trennen kann und dass auch wenn es nicht ihre Premiere vom Gesetzgeber zu gewiesene Aufgabe ist, sehr wohl auch solche Angelegenheiten mit Systembetreibern diskutiert werden. Der sozusagen Anknüpfungspunkt ist hier die Sorgfaltspflicht, die Unternehmen damit haben, wenn sie personenbezogene Daten verarbeiten.
Also heißt Datenschützer, Rechtsanwälte oder Chaos Computer Club Leute sind erstmal gute Anspielfreunde. Ich hab noch irgendwie im Hinterkopf, wir haben so einen komischen Briefkasten.
Ja klar, also wir nehmen natürlich auch gerne, ich sag mal, es gibt ja auch so Datenunfälle, es gibt Datenspenden, es gibt ja alle möglichen Formen. Unter Umständen ist es ja für jemanden, der eine Sicherheitslücke entdeckt oder der in einem System drin ist, ist es gar nicht dem seine Motivation jetzt dafür einen Orden zu bekommen, seinen Namen in die Welt zu posaun oder dem Systembetreiber jetzt mit irgendwelchen pädagogischen Verhandlungen gegenüberzusetzen, sondern es geht einfach darum, dass vielleicht auch eine Datensauerei entdeckt worden ist, die öffentlich gemacht werden muss. Und dafür stehen sowohl wir zur Verfügung, es gibt auch Seiten wie Wikileaks, die, ich sag mal, darauf spezialisiert sind, Material, was eigentlich der Öffentlichkeit dringend zugänglich gemacht werden muss, das dann eben auch zugänglich zu machen.
Also man sollte auch sagen, selbst wenn man jetzt mit einem Kumpel als neutralen Zwischenmann geht, ist das schon ein Vorteil. Aber es ist noch nicht die Lösung. Man sieht ganz deutlich bei dieser Studi-VZ-Sache, der eine geht direkt hin, der andere... Schüler-VZ, naja, ist ja sehr beladen. Also der eine geht direkt hin und wird inhaftiert und er anregt über netzpolitik.org und läuft heute noch rum und keiner weiß, wie er heißt. Also das ist auf jeden Fall sinnvoll, nicht direkt mit denen zu reden, aber wenn man schon jemanden nimmt, sagen wir dann, überlegt euch das vorher. Nicht den Bruder hinschicken oder so. Das kann nur in die Hose gehen.
Der Bruder ist immer sauer, als wenn man mal das Matchbox-Auto früher geklaut hat. Okay, jetzt haben wir die ganze Zeit quasi davon geredet und auch Geschichten erzählt. Es gibt ein ganz praktisches Beispiel, wenn ihr da draußen sitzt und denkt so, ha, ist mir auch schon passiert, habe ich damals das entdeckt, könnt ihr gerne anrufen, denn ihr wisst ja eigentlich, das ist eine Sendung, wo ihr immer mit an Start sein könnt. Also falls ihr noch eine Sicherheitslücke habt, die ihr irgendwie über gleich ein großes Publikum verteilen wollt, dann könnt ihr jetzt gerne anrufen. Christian hat das auch gemacht. Hallo Christian. Was ist dir denn passiert?
Mir ist passiert, das war vor ungefähr zwei Jahren, da ist so ein D1-Discount-Reseller auf den Markt gegangen und die haben zum einen so Nummern, die man sich nicht merken kann und dann so ganz tolle VIP-Nummern verkauft. Und die VIP-Nummern haben natürlich extra gekostet.
Was sind VIP-Nummern? So was wie 9999999?
Ja genau, also mit ganz vielen sich wiederholenden Zahlen und wenig verschiedenen Zahlen und so. Genau und für die, die sich ein bisschen mit HTML auskennen, sie haben halt ist VIP-Nummer 1 oder 0 übergeben und auf der Seite, wo die Daten angekommen sind, nicht nochmal überprüft und daran festgestellt, ob das eine VIP-Nummer ist oder nicht. Und da kann man ja dann ziemlich einfach das einfach ändern, VIP-Nummer aussuchen, allerdings statt 1 und 0 mit senden. Und schon hatte man die VIP-Nummer für umme.
Das ist die alte Methode, die noch älteste Methode mit Sicherheitslücken umzugehen, der Gentleman zahlt und schweigt.
Genau, ich habe mir gedacht, hey, bist ein guter Mensch, versuchst mal da den Geschäftsführer dran zu kriegen, weil an der Hotline wollte mir eh keiner Gehör schenken. Per E-Mail habe ich es auch probiert. Ich hatte dann irgendwann den Geschäftsführer dran, habe den auch davon erzählt. Der war mäßig begeistert, dass ich seine Nummer rausgefunden habe. Das war aber sein einziges Problem mit der Sache. Also der hat sich da nicht wirklich groß drum gekümmert. Ich habe das zwei Wochen lang versucht, dass die das mal ändern, weil, keine Ahnung, das geschadet denen ja doch auch. Und nach zwei Wochen habe ich mir dann gesagt, so, nee, jetzt reicht es mir, habe das auf zwei bis drei Foren gepostet, das Ganze ist ein bisschen rumgegangen. Und vier Tage später war das dann gefixt.
Kann man sich vermutlich leicht merken?
Nee, meine Handynummer, ich habe das selber nicht gemacht. Ich habe das nur getestet, es war im Warenkorb. Nee, wirklich nicht, weil warum will ich jemand anders einen finanziellen Schaden anrichten? Da habe ich so viel Ethik, dass ich das nicht möchte. Irgendwann, als die es dann aber nicht begreifen wollten, meine Güte, wie es Fefe gesagt hat, solange kein Druck da ist, wird es nicht gefixt. Soll ich den Namen nennen?
Genau, es geht nur um mittelständische, oder von den Telefon-Giganten.
Das ist einer von den größeren D1 Resellern, die es also die Discounter, die es schon länger gibt und immer noch gibt, die jetzt ihr Angebot auf Auto umschwenken.
Das reicht, glaube ich, für alle, die es wissen wollen.
Ungefähr eine Idee. Nach dem, was ich heute gehört habe hier im Chaosradio, ist das aber, wie es Christian gemacht hat, zwar sozusagen eine noble Absicht, aber eigentlich nicht ganz sauber. Hätte er es anders machen sollen?
Je nach Unternehmensgröße und Art, in diesem Fall würde ich ihm jetzt keinen Vorwurf machen, weil das Unternehmen direkt zu kontaktieren, ist in diesem Fall ja tatsächlich nett. Er hat ja nicht sozusagen was ausgenutzt, er hat da keine Daten gestohlen, er hat gesagt, ihr habt da ein Problem. Auch das kann aber bei Unternehmen, die eine merkwürdige Kultur haben, schon dazu führen, dass die einfach mal sofort eine Strafanzeige stellen und sagen müssen, sie haben da irgendwas bei uns ausgenutzt und da haben wir keine Lust drauf.
Ganz konkret ist es, hätte Christian auch passieren können, dass der Geschäftsführer sagt, Alter, du hast jetzt gleich mal eine Strafanzeige an der Backe, weil du hast unseren Shop gehackt.
Ja, so ungefähr. Man muss einfach sagen, es gibt Unternehmen, die reagieren so, auch wenn da vor Gericht nichts bei rauskommt, hat man halt erst mal den Ärger am Hals.
Das ist eine Krisen-PR-Sache. Man kann sich das ja überlegen, wenn die Firma denkt, dass sie mehr Vorteile daraus schlagen kann, dass in der Presse steht, wir haben eine Anzeige gegen den bösen Hacker gemacht, als dass in der Presse steht, die sind gehackt worden, dann werden die im Zweifelsfall eine Anzeige machen. Und ob die das jetzt tun oder nicht, hängt im Normalfall davon ab, wie weit Privatsphäre deren Geschäftsmodell trifft oder nicht. Also beim Telekom-Laden, die hätten wahrscheinlich bösereagiert, wenn das Problem gewesen wäre, dass man andere Leute in Mailboxen abhören kann oder so.
So ist es quasi nur ein kleines Geldproblem.
So ist es nur ein kleines Ding gewesen und da kann man schon mal fünfgegerade sein lassen. Aber bei einer Bank, normalerweise, wenn man denen erzählt, ich kann hier die Kontoauszüge von anderen Leuten einsehen, dann ist das schon eine ganz andere Sache. Und dann werden die auch deutlich unentspannter reagieren.
Ja, aber Christian hat sich richtig Mühe gegeben. Er hat sozusagen die Nummern rausgesucht und hat immer wieder angerufen. Was wäre eure Empfehlung das nächste Mal? Also angenommen, Christian stolpert morgen bei einem Reseller über die Möglichkeit, sich tolle Telefonnummern irgendwie für umsonst geben zu lassen. Wie macht das das nächste Mal?
Also er kann sicherlich eine Mail an mail.cccde schreiken.
Moment, Moment. Also es gibt mail.cccde. Das ist unser normaler Posteingang. Aber wenn ihr einen Hack zu berichten habt, dann wollt ihr im Zweifelsfall PGP verschlüsseln. Und die Mailadresse beim ccc mit PGP-Eingang ist ds für Datenschleuder. ds.cccde. Da gibt es auch einen PGP-Key. Und da könnt ihr nach googeln oder auf den Kieserband gucken. Also im Normalfall mail.ccc.de für Sachen, die unkritisch sind. Aber wenn es euch betrifft, wenn ihr im Knast landet, wenn es jemand sieht, dann nehmt PGP und schreibt an ds.ccc.de.
Christian, nach den Sachen, die du heute gehört hast, würdest du es jetzt anders machen oder würdest du es noch mal genau so machen?
Also das, was ich heute gehört habe, verwundert mich zum einen erstmal gar nicht. Ich würde es einfach gar nicht mehr machen, weil wozu soll ich mir die Arbeit machen, wenn es den Leuten dann eh wurscht ist. Ich würde es vertrauensvoll an jemand weitergeben, von dem ich der Meinung bin, dass der Vernünftiges damit anstellt und würde dann meine Finger draus lassen, wenn es sowas ist. Weil den Aufwand ist es meiner Meinung nach nicht wirklich wert bei solchen Dingen. Wenn es natürlich irgendwie ein schwerwiegendes Problem ist, dass das Internet kaputt geht oder so, dann sieht das Ganze wieder anders aus. Aber so eine kleine Firma, die man pro Bestellung um 20 Euro bescheißen kann, das schadet der Firma, aber nicht der Allgemeinheit.
Gut, aber wir hatten auch Beispiele, zum Beispiel am Anfang, als diese Geschichte mit den offenen WLANs zu rumging. Da sind wir auch durch Berlin gefahren, haben verschiedene Unternehmen dabei quasi entdeckt, wie sie ihre Daten in die Berliner Luft verteilen. Und da kann man sich dann darüber amüsieren. Man kann auch mal mit dem Unternehmen Rücksprache halten. Allerdings der Fall, wo wir dann richtig aktiv geworden sind, als wir halt Krankenhausdaten entdeckt haben, wo denn irgendwelche Ärzte auf Notfalls automatische Diagnosesysteme gefüttert haben.
Ja, und das Schließsystem der Türen vom Deutschen Bundestag war auch mal im WLAN.
Ja gut, aber bei diesen personbezogene Geschichten, da geht man dann schon los, geht zum Datenschutz vor Auftragten und der kann dann den notwendigen Druck machen. Also es hängt immer davon ab, aber ich gebe dir recht, wenn Unternehmen, also wenn es keine Kultur gibt, dafür dankbar zu sein, wenn man Leute darauf aufmerksam macht, dass sie da ein Problem haben, dann stellt sich natürlich auch die Frage, warum soll man sich dann auch noch in eine Gefahr bringen, dafür Ärger zu bekommen.
Also im Zweifelsfall würde ich zu Hause gehen mit solchen Sachen oder zu irgendwelchen Branchen, Magazinen.
Hauptsache man ist selber aus der Nummer raus. Christian, vielen Dank erstmal für die Geschichte. Und wenn ihr da draußen sitzt und so etwas Ähnliches erlebt habt, dann ruft jetzt an, 0331 70 97 110 ist die Nummer dafür. Und jetzt haben wir ja die ganze Zeit über Dinge geredet, die jetzt sagen wir mal nicht hoch dramatisch sind, weil klar, man kriegt vielleicht eine Strafanzeige, aber das ist jetzt nicht so schlimm. Aber der Titel heißt ja, oder wie man als Hacker am Leben bleibt, ist das wirklich eine Sache, über die man sich Gedanken machen muss?
Ja, leider. Also es gab einige Fälle im CCC-Umfeld, wo also Leute tatsächlich ums Leben gekommen sind. Und deswegen meinen wir das tatsächlich so, wenn wir sagen, wenn ihr mit also mit Geheimdiensten zu tun habt, zum Beispiel, oder mit irgendwelchen organisierten Kriminalitätsstrukturen, dann ist das durchaus noch die positive Variante, wenn die die Polizei rufen und ihr im Knast landet. Das kann durchaus schlechter ausgehen für euch. Deswegen, wenn ihr da Zweifel habt, mit wem ihr es zu tun habt, dann macht es lieber nicht, sondern geht zur Presse.
Das hört sich schon ein bisschen nach Agenda-Story an. Wie schnell geht es denn, dass man an einen Punkt kommt, wo wirklich dann zu sagen, wo man mit solchen Leuten zu tun hat? Also stolpert man darüber oder muss man das schon auch wollen?
Na, da gibt es beide Varianten. Es gab ja in den 80er Jahren einige Leute aus dem Umfeld, die irgendwie in Geldnot auf die merkwürdige Idee kamen, sich jetzt dem KGB als Dienstleister anzubieten, um westliche Systeme, in Anführungszeichen, z.B. in welche Software zu besorgen. Wenn man weiß, dass man für den Geheimdienst arbeitet, dann weiß man halt vielleicht auch oder hat eine Ahnung davon, mit wem man sich da einlässt. Aber es gibt natürlich auch Systeme. Wir hatten beispielsweise jemanden, der mit Smartcards hohe Begabungen hatte, sich die anzugucken. Und da ist man auf einmal in Gebäudesicherungssystemen. Hat das eine Relevanz, wo auf einmal Atombomben damit bewacht werden? Und entsprechend sind da ganz andere Akteure Militärs auf einmal von betroffen. Und auch wenn man glaubt, es geht doch hier nur um so ein paar Bits in unser Plastikstückchen, ist da draußen ganz schön was los. Es gab also auch in den letzten paar Jahren Beispiele, wo wir dann Meldungen hatten, dass in einigen Ländern auf einmal Militärs angefangen, ihre Gebäude anders zu bewachen und mehr Personal. Weil es also Veröffentlichungen gab beziehungsweise Gerüchte gab, jemanden im Vortrag gehalten hatte, auch wie man ein bestimmtes Zugangskontrollsystem, was auf Smartcats und der FID basierte, hacken konnte. Und das heißt, unter Umständen sieht man nicht immer gleich die Anwendung, die da hinstellt und man sieht auch nicht immer gleich, um wie viel Geld es da geht, weil ab einer sechs, sieben, achtstelligen Dimension ist halt so ein Budget für eine Observation für Maßnahmen, die nichts mehr mit der Polizei zu tun haben, auf einmal auch so unter Ferner liefen im Budget enthalten.
Also wir müssen auch noch sagen, ums Leben kommen heißt nicht unbedingt, dass man stirbt, sondern es kann auch so was wie dieser UFO-Hacker sein, von dem ihr vielleicht gehört habt. Gary McKinnon heißt ja, das ist ein Britte, ein Nerd wie ein Buch steht, der an UFOs glaubt und der irgendwann gedacht hat, naja, also wenn jemand Beweise dafür hat, dass die UFOs gelandet sind bei uns, dann ja wohl die NASA und dann hat er angefangen bei der NASA rumzuhacken. Und die NASA ist halt eine zivile Behörde, die haben da durchaus nicht so viel Geld für Computersicherheit wie andere Stellen der US-Regierung und als die es halt rausgekriegt haben, ging die Sache ans Department of Homeland Security und der Gary McKinnon wehrt sich seit mehreren Jahren jetzt dagegen, dass die Briten ihn ausliefern. Mit PIN bis zum Europäischen Gerichtshof für Menschenrechte versucht er sich geradezu zu wehren.
Was würde ihm da blühen, wenn das doch passiert?
Das weiß man halt nicht, aber ich meine, in Guantanamo wird es ja nicht enden wollen. Und selbst wenn er da nur im normalen Knast landet, bis sie die Sache beschlossen und untersucht haben, kann sich das noch zehn Jahre hinziehen. Also die Folgenabschätzung ist immer eine sehr schwierige Sache. Und im Zweifelsfall müsst ihr davon ausgehen, dass ihr das nicht überblicken könnt, was da gerade passiert. Und deswegen lieber nicht selber versuchen, irgendwelche Dinge zu klären. Wir haben auf dem Kongress, wer so lange warten kann, haben wir auf dem Kongress immer eine Ethikkotline eingerichtet seit ein paar Jahren. Da könnt ihr dann anrufen, euer Problem schildern. Am besten gleich vor Ort mit einem Decktelefon. Oder ihr könnt auch einfach live hinkommen und uns vor Ort fragen. Also wenn ihr es nicht wisst, dann fragt lieber jemanden. Weil da sind doch Sachen auf dem Spiel, die man nicht im jeden Fall vorher überblicken kann.
Es gab auch einen amerikanischen Kollegen, der hat mal herausgefunden, dass es in Amerika nicht illegal ist, aus Amerika aus französische Computer zu hacken. Weil die Straftat selbst sich ja nicht in Amerika abschüttet, sondern eben in Frankreich. Auch wenn der Straftäter in Anführungszeichen oder der Täter halt in Amerika sitzt. Er hat darüber veröffentlicht und die Reaktion war, dass der französische Botschafter zum US-Ausministerium gekommen ist und gesagt hat, wissen Sie was, es ist ganz einfach, Angriffe auf französische Computer aus amerikanischen Datennetzen raus, werden wir als Angriffskrieg interpretieren und entsprechend verantworten. What? Der hatte dann richtig einen Stoßtrupp FBI im Haus, die ihm also gesagt haben, naja, das ist schon richtig, dass das nicht illegal ist nach derzeitiger amerikanischer Rechtsprechung, aber sie würden ihm doch nahelegen.
Das hat andere Konsequenzen.
Sie würden ihm doch nahelegen, das nicht zu tun. Und ja, man, also wie gesagt, das sind teilweise, hat man da mit einer Welt zu tun, die ganz anders funktioniert und wo Sicherheit ganz anders definiert ist und wo es auch nicht immer darum geht, was jetzt hier legal oder illegal ist. Und das ist halt tatsächlich so, ich meine, dass man sich dieser Welt nicht unbedingt bewusst und mit voller Absicht widmet, das ist die eine Sache, aber manchmal gerät man ja auch in Sachen rein, wo man sagen muss, um Himmels willen, was ist denn hier eigentlich? Und spätestens dann ist der Zeitpunkt, sich also an vielleicht Institutionen zu wenden, ob das jetzt wir sind, ob das andere sind, die mit der notwendigen Offenheit da herangehen. Weil tatsächlich Offenheit ist die beste Schutz vor Erpressung und auch wenn da vielleicht schon Dinge passiert sind, die nicht so buchstäblich mit dem Gesetz vereinbart sind, lassen sich auch oft Regelungen finden, da wenigstens noch halbwegs sauber rauszukommen, bevor also diese ganze, wie soll ich sagen, bevor man darauf wartet, dass der Systembetreiber mit seinen Mitteln reagiert.
Es ist also noch eine ganze Spur komplexer, wird auch eine ganze Spur komplexer. Wir haben gleich noch eine halbe Stunde Zeit, um darüber noch ausführlicher zu reden. Das müssen wir noch genau erklären, dass es halt auch gefährlich werden kann. Also wir reden jetzt nicht von irgendwie Gefängnis oder irgendwas, sondern richtig gefährlich. Wenn man zu leichtfertig mit solchen Sachen umgeht. Wir hören vorher aber noch kurz Musik, machen dann nach dem Wetter und Verkehr und dann geht's weiter. Ihr könnt währenddessen noch weiter anrufen unter 0331 70 97 110.
Wer?
Hier wird gerade wilde Beschuldigungen werden hier um sich geworfen. Es gäbe hier Internet-süchtige Leute. Das kann ich mir gar nicht vorstellen, wenn der Chaos Computer Club hier am Start ist. Das war gerade Eyeballs and Elbows von Datazette, Musik aus dem Netz. Wir werden gleich noch mal drüber reden, was man macht, wenn man dann sozusagen einen Schritt zu weit gegangen ist. Außerdem haben wir ein paar sehr interessante Anrufe an dir. In der Leitung werden wir über Funk-Schnittstellen für medizinische Geräte reden oder Vollzugriff auf Mailserver von einem großen Telekommunikationsunternehmen. Das alles gleich. Vorher machen wir aber Nachrichten mit Wetter und Verkehr.
Steckt ein Cover-Song von einem der erfolgreichsten Künstler des Jahres.
Hmm, wer könnte das nur sein?
Der Fritz.
Adventscoverländer. Mehr davon ab dem kommenden Dienstag. Tagt natürlich auf Hey!
Und das hört man um halb zwölf. Nachrichten mit Kaietan Dülich.
Im Berliner Stadtteil Prenzlauer Berg am Linke ging die Räumung eines besetzten Hauses in Berlin-Mitte demonstriert. Laut Polizei zogen 750 Demonstranten vom Kollwitzplatz Richtung Nordbahnhof. Die Polizei war mit einem Großaufgebot vor Ort. Die Demo verlief ruhig. Die Berliner Polizei hatte gestern Nachmittag ein links-alternatives Wohnprojekt in der Brunnenstraße geräumt, weil die rund 20 Bewohner dort illegal gewohnt haben. Bundeskanzlerin Merkel hat die Entscheidung von General Motors begrüßt, dass in Deutschland keine Opelwerke geschlossen werden sollen. Merkel sagte am Abend, dass alle Standorte trotz geplanter Stellenstreichungen eine gute Perspektive hätten. GM hatte heute das Sanierungskonzept für Opel vorgestellt. Demnach sollen in Deutschland fast 5000 Jobs gestrichen werden. In Deutschland wird schon wieder über die Zukunft des Solidaritätszuschlags gestritten. Auslöser ist ein Urteil des niedersächsischen Finanzgerichts, das Sinzoli als Grundgesetz widrig einstufte. Nun soll das Bundesverfassungsgericht entscheiden. Die FDP hatte vorgeschlagen, die Sonderabgabe für den Aufbauarzt schrittweise abzubauen. Die CDU-CSU dagegen ist weiterhin für den Soli. Der verhaftete Filmemacher Roman Polanski wird gegen eine Kaution von 3 Millionen Euro aus dem Gefängnis entlassen. Polanski muss alle Ausweispapiere abgeben und wird unter Hausarrest gestellt. Im Gericht zur Folge könnte ihm dafür eine elektronische Fußfessel angelegt werden. Polanski war Ende September festgenommen worden, weil er Ende der 70er ein damals 13-jähriges Mädchen missbraucht haben soll. Er wurde bekannt unter anderem für den Film Tanz der Vampire. In der Fußball-Championsliga hat Bayer München seine Chance auf das Erreichen des Achtelfinales bewahrt. Bayer München gewann am Abend im vorletzten Gruppenspiel gegen den israelischen Club Maccabi Haifa 1 zu 0. Der deutsche Meister Wolfsburg hatte dagegen sein vorletztes Gruppenspiel verloren und das gegen Moskau mit 1 zu 2. Es bleibt wolkig heute Nacht, vereinzelt gibt es auch ein bisschen Nieselregen, ansonsten weitestgehend trocken. Die Tiefstädte liegen in dieser Nacht zwischen 7 bis 9 Grad. Die aktuellen Werte in Potsdam, Cottbusen, Neurupien und Angermünde 10 Grad, Frankfurt, Wittenberge 11 Grad und in Berlin auch um die 10 bis 11 Grad. Morgen bleibt es erst recht freundlich, später dann wird es wolkiger, aber es bleibt dann meistens trocken. Dabei ist es relativ mild, morgen mit Höchstwerten von 13 Grad. Vorsicht auf der A13 Berlin Richtung Dresden, zwischen Teupitz und Baruth-Mark, da liegen Gegenstände auf der Fahrbahn rum. Und aus dem Stadtverkehr Berlin zwei Meldungen, die kommen beide vom Stadtring 100 Richtung Neukölln-Treptow, zwischen der Beusselstraße und dem Dreieck Charlottenburg, da gibt es zwei Kilometer stockenden Verkehr und zwischen der Beusselstraße und dem Spandauer Damm, dort zwei Kilometer Stau. Euch eine gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn im Radio 103, 1, dann Fritz in der Prieknitz.
Die zwei Sprechstunden mit Marius Richter, mit Fefe und mit Andy im Chaos Radio im letzten in diesem Jahr und es geht um Responsible Disclosure oder eigentlich um Disclosure im Allgemeinen und wie man als Hacker im Leben bleibt. Da fällt mir ein im Chat zur Sendung, ne im Blog zur Sendung wurde gerade kommentiert, das heißt, das hieße gar nicht Hacker, man müsse Hacker sagen. Jetzt aus berufenden Munde die beiden anwesenden Experten vom Chaos Computer Club. Wie heißt es wirklich? Ja, Datenreisende heißt es also wirklich, wer es ganz genau nehmen will. So, wir hatten gerade vor den Nachrichten darüber gesprochen, dass es, wenn man so Sicherheitslücken am Start hat und damit in Bereiche kommt, die ein bisschen diffiziler sind, dass man da auch durchaus in Richtung Militär oder Geheimdienst an den Start sein kann. Kann man das vorher wissen oder ist es dann einfach so, auf einmal steht jemand vor der Tür und meint hallo?
Na im Allgemeinen weiß man das schon vorher. Also ich meine, wie soll man sagen, rückblickend ist man ja immer schlauer. Aber wenn man mal, so viele Fälle gibt es ja auch nicht, aber wenn man bei den Fällen, die wir da hatten, rückblickt, dann muss man sagen, naja klar, sicher. Und die Hacker wussten das auch und hätten auch noch aussteigen können, wenn sie rechtzeitig gewollt hätten. Aber man legt sich ja, wenn man so eine große Entscheidung trifft, eben auch vorher seine Gründe zurecht, warum man das jetzt tut. Und wenn man jung ist und glaubt irgendwie, man hat die Welt verdient, ja, und da kommt ein Geheimdienst und bietet einem alles, was man schon immer haben wollte. Und das ist ja deren Kernkompetenz, dass sie genau wissen, womit sie dich ködern können.
Also es gibt ja auch sogenannte Honeypots, das sind Systeme, die mehr oder weniger als Systeme, die jetzt militärsklassifiziert sind, die auch so aussehen und sich so anfühlen, wie so ein Militärsystem. Und da kann man aber irgendwie doch reinhacken. Und das sind nichts weiter als, wenn man so will, Personalakquise-Instrumente. Wenn also ein Militär gute Hacker sucht, dann schalten die keine Anzeigen und sagen, hey, wenn ihr irgendwie tolle Hacker seid, dann meldet euch mal, sondern die stellen so Honeypots ins Netz. Und wir dann sehen, okay, da kommt jemand relativ weit. Das ist alles eine simulierte Umgebung. Dann findet man schon Methoden, denjenigen aufzuspüren. Man musste also nicht mehr seinen Personalbewerbungsbogen ausfüllen und irgendwie seine Daten eintragen. Dafür gibt es ja Vorratsdatenspeicherung und ähnliche Instrumente.
Also es gibt es auch manchmal so, dass es nicht als Hunnipod geplant ist, sondern dass sie einfach gucken, oh, wer hat uns denn hier den Webserver aufgemacht? Und dann besuchen sie den halt und sagen, junger Mann, du hast zwei Optionen, 20 Jahre Knast oder eine Karriere beim Militär.
Ist das wirklich dann die einzige Option, die man noch hat oder kann man dann immer auf die Hände hochreißen und sagen, ey, Moment mal.
Ja, man kann auch alles leugnen und dann wird man in den U-Haft gesteckt und dann wird ein paar Jahre durch einen Grinder geschoben. Also ja, ich meine, man kann sich auch auf die Justiz verlassen, aber im Zweifelsfall, ja.
Am Teil soll man sozusagen nicht so doll rumspielen.
Im Zweifelsfall soll man es nicht so weit kommen lassen.
Nee, militärische Systeme sind nicht geschickt.
Atomkraftwerke sind auch nicht geschickt.
Wobei es gab, war früher in der Welt der Wächsen, gab es so eine Zementfabrik, die hat eine Menge Wächsen rumstehen, also wie gesagt 80er Jahre und keiner hat gedacht, dass das irgendwas kritisches ist, bis sich dann später, nachdem die sozusagen die Staatsmacht mobilisiert haben, herausgestellt haben, dass es eine Zementfabrik für so Raketensilos war, die so Spezialzement da gefertigt haben und dann doch etwas empfindlich waren, dass ihre Computer nicht mehr unter ihrer Kontrolle standen.
Okay, also man kann sagen, ungefähr auf der Jobanleitung kommen, sollte man aber echt überlegen, wo man gerade so Sicherheitsdruckung auflegt. Wir haben jetzt ein paar Kandidaten in der Leitung, denen möglicherweise ein solches Gespräch bald bevorsteht. Als erstes den Friedo Lin. Was hast du am Start?
Tja, das Ganze fing eigentlich ziemlich harmlos an. Also bei mir in der Familie gibt es Leute, die medizinischen Gebret brauchen und dann habe ich mir das an mir gesehen und plötzlich festgestellt, dass da drin eine Funkschnittstelle sich befindet.
Was für ein Gerät war das genau?
Na in dem Falle war es eine Insulinpumpe. So und da drin befindet sich Bluetooth.
Oh, da hast du aber eine sehr moderne erwischt. Hast du eine moderne erwischt?
Ja, eigentlich so die einzige auf dem Markt, die das hat.
Ja, bei uns in Amerika ist das nicht Bluetooth, sondern ein eigenes Protokoll.
Ja und dann habe ich mich mit der Firma auseinandergesetzt und bin jetzt seit gut vier Wochen mit der Firma in heftigem telefonischen Kontakt gewesen.
Also okay, da gibt es ein medizinisches Gerät und das hat Bluetooth. Das ist ja jetzt erstmal nicht schlimm. Warum genau bist du jetzt in Kontakt mit der Firma?
Ja, dann habe ich dort angerufen, um zu erfahren, was für Protokolle denn da gesprochen werden oder ob sie mir irgendwie so ein paar Hausnummern geben könnten, an denen man abschätzen könnte, dass dieses Gerät jetzt nicht völlig sicherheitskritisch ist. Und da bin ich auch entsprechend durchgereicht worden und hatte mich mit einem Techniker unterhalten, der so ein bisschen hin und her druckste, versuchte dann auch noch ein paar Sachen zu sagen, allerdings kam dann nicht viel bei raus. Und seit vier Wochen, wie gesagt, war ich in heftigem telefonischen Kontakt, sondern sollte mir auch eigentlich ein Zertifikat des Fraunhofer Institutes zur Verfügung gestellt werden, wo das alles drin stand. Und relativ plötzlich, also ich bin dann immer an eine Person gekommen, die sich konkret um mich gekümmert hat, wo dann auch klar war, dass wenn ich anrief, sofort zu dieser Person durchgestellt werden musste. Am Anfang habe ich noch mit vielen Personen gesprochen, die auch unterschiedliche Sachen gesagt haben, wo man so ein bisschen hier und da auch mal was abklopfen konnte. Und dann war das aber nur noch über diese eine Person, wo das schon ziemlich forciert wurde, dass da ein Protokoll war. Und dann sprach die mich plötzlich mit dem Namen einer Person bei mir aus der Familie an. Und ob ich dem der Sohn so sei. Und ich sag, nee, das wäre ich nicht. Das wäre mein Verwandter. Und das ist jetzt auch nicht weiter erstaunlich. Ich kann mir schon ungefähr vorstellen, aus welchem Bereich das kam. Aber man hatte sich auf der anderen Seite schon doch recht intensiv Gedanken gemacht. Und dann hab ich jetzt weiter versucht zu erfahren, was denn dahinter steckt irgendwie. Also in diesem Protokoll einfach nur, sollen sie mir sagen, da ist ein IIS drinsteckt oder so was und das irgendwo verbrieft oder sonst was. Und mit etlichen Fragen, warum ich das denn wissen wollte und so weiter, ist dann irgendwo der Kontakt abgebrochen. Und jetzt ist immer noch so ein bisschen, es sind neue Quellen aufgetan worden. Ich hab mich jetzt auch an Heise gewendet. Also vorher hatte ich mich schon an Heise gewendet, die da Interesse dran bekundet haben. Allerdings so mit so einem Satz, wenn da was Interessantes bei rauskommt, dann auf jeden Fall. Also zu Deutsch, da will man irgendwie auch nicht aktiv werden. Das ist auch irgendwo verständlich, weil das ist vermutlich viel Arbeit, Sachen rauszufinden. Ich hab da Patentschrift oder einige Patentschriften dann bekommen über Personen, die sich da im Netz mal umgetan haben. Das soll auch frei zugänglich gewesen sein. Na ja, und das ist, das sagte mir dann diese Person dann auch schon, dass man bei so großen medizinischen Unternehmen na ja zumindest vorsichtig sein soll, weil für die ist es günstig, ein Privatdetektiv einfach mal so ein paar Tage gucken zu lassen, ob das ein Idiot ist, der jetzt gerade irgendwie nur Langeweile hat oder ob das jetzt jemand potentiell gefährlich ist.
Vor allem ist es doch gleich versuchter Totschlag, wenn du da was findest. Also da muss man, das ist nicht nur hacken, also da musst du sehr, sehr vorsichtig sein. Vielleicht um die Sache ein bisschen abzukürzen, ja, es ist uns bekannt, es ist nicht nur bei Insulinpumpen so, auch bei Herzschrittmachern. Da gab es auch Fälle, bei denen man so einen Herzschrittmacher unidirektional manipulieren kann. Also man musste gar nicht mit dem reden, sondern es reichte denen zu erreichen. Das heißt mit einer großen Antenne hätte man quasi eine ganze Halle irgendwie runterfahren können. Und ja, das ist ein echtes Problem, aber das ist auch so ein Mindsetproblem, dass die Mediziner normalerweise überhaupt nicht davon ausgehen, dass jemand was tun könnte, um einem Patienten zu schaden. Sondern die gehen nur davon aus, dass alle Leute im Grunde das Gute des Patienten im Auge haben und das ist alles Personal, was ihre Geräte bedient geschult ist. Und ja, also das ist ein generelles Problem.
Das habe ich die letzten Wochen echt intensiver fahren dürfen.
Genau, so ist es.
Und habe versucht das noch. Also es wurde immer wieder gefragt und auch mit den unterschiedlichsten, in den unterschiedlichsten Situationen, warum ich das denn wissen wollte und so weiter und so fort. Und entweder man weigert sich kategorisch auf der anderen Seite oder man hat wirklich ein völlig anderes Verständnis von, also ich habe dann eben von Sicherheit, ich sagte dann eben, dass Sicherheit eigentlich nur dadurch entstehen kann, so ein bisschen geprägt auch durch den CCC, dass man eben dieses Vielaugenprinzip hätte. Und da fielen dann so langsam die Schotten. Ich wurde auch gefragt, ob ich zum CCC gehören würde. Ja, also das ist noch nicht...
Um das mal ganz klar zu machen, du hast nicht selber den Blumen rumgebastelt, sondern hast tatsächlich einfach nur penetrant die Frage gestellt, wie sicher ist das Gerät?
Nein, ich wäre einen Meilen weit davon entfernt, eine Pumpe zu öffnen oder sowas. Nein, nein, das ist nicht der Punkt. Sollte es bedarfsisch liegen, gibt es sicherlich versehentlich mitgeschnittenes Material. Aber das wäre natürlich schon... Also das wäre sowieso per se jetzt der nächste Schritt gewesen, sich mal an den CCC zu wenden und einfach mal nachzufragen, ob da was bekannt ist und wenn man Luftschnittstelle bräuchte oder sowas, dann...
Also ja, das wollte ich dich gerade fragen. Was ist denn der offizielle Zweck dieser Luftschnittstelle? Ist das für Wartungszwecke oder ist das für die normale Steuerung?
Nee, nee, nee, nee, das ist noch geiler. Man hat ein Zuckermessgerät und in diesem Zuckermessgerät werden die Werte erhoben und da kann man eben entsprechende Diagramme sehen und so weiter. Weiter ist es dann allerdings geplant, sowohl die Basalrate, also die durchlaufende Insulinrate, als auch die konkret gesetzte Einheit an die Pumpe zu senden und diese kann beispielsweise im BH getragen werden bei Frauen und dann ohne Kontakt mit der Pumpe direkt über das Messgerät können Einheiten gesetzt werden. Das heißt, es ist durchaus geplant, dass es den Zweck des Systems, Insulingaben über die Funkschnittstelle zu verabreichen.
Genau, das ist auch bei den Hersteller machen so.
Ja und das ist natürlich...
Also da stellst du natürlich andere Sachen an als Insulin an. Aber ja, da kannst du Leute mit töten, um das mal zusammenzufassen.
Genau, das habe ich dann eben auch veranführt und sagte, nehmen wir einfach mal den Politiker, der, ich sag jetzt mal, in seinem Rollstuhl irgendwie eine Insulinpumpe hat. Na ja, das wäre natürlich potenziell recht gefährlich. Also das kann man nicht anders sagen. Also wirklich, die Firma hat sich dann damit geäußert, dass es hieß, es sei ja nicht bekannt, welcher Politiker Insulinpumpen hätte. Und dann habe ich eben angeführt, ich könnte höchstwahrscheinlich rausfinden, welcher Politiker...
Das kann man mit dem Blut so sagen.
Ja, lass es mir mal so sein. Es gibt ja auch Gefährdungen, die dadurch entstehen, dass jemand einfach rumprobiert oder dass andere Blutus-Geräte rumsenden, weil dann unter Umständen Latenzen entstehen. Das heißt, da die Zeitabläufe sich verschieben zwischen dem Messgerät und die eigentliche Aktivität dann stattfinden. Und solche Latenzen sind unter Umständen auch schon negativ für die Lebensfunktion des Patienten.
Ja gut, es ist wohl so, also ich habe das in so weit in Erfahrung bringen können, dass wenn jemand dazwischen funkt, dass dann die Verbindung aus, also abbricht und auch dafür gesorgt wird, dass dann eben, dass das aktiv abgebrochen wird und man wohl schweigt auf beiden Seiten. Das scheint man schon mal gut gemacht zu haben, also dass es eben da dann keinen noch mal Nachfragen gibt, wo man dann irgendwie einen Test gegenfahren könnte. Einfach mal so lange probieren oder sowas. Also man schweigt, wenn es falsch ist, auf beiden Seiten. Und es ist so, dass mir gesagt wurde, man würde die Bluetooth-Verschlüsseln verwenden und wenn diese geknackt würde, da konnte ich erst mal lachen, wenn diese geknackt würde, dann würde darunter noch ein proprietäres Verfahren für die Verschlüsselung greifen.
Ja, da darf man leider nicht viel drauf geben. Also wir wissen grundsätzlich von der Problematik und wir versuchen auch jedes Jahr wieder aktiv Leute zum Kongress einzuladen, die uns da mal Details erzählen. Aber das ist leider nicht so ganz einfach. Also eines der Highlights hätte, ich glaube auf dem letzten Kongress war das ein Typ sein sollen, der da seine Prothese hacken wollte. Er hat dann aber leider abgesagt vorher. Also ja, wenn ihr euch damit beschäftigt und mehr darüber wisst, als ja, da gibt es was, da könnte vielleicht was gehen, dann kommt bitte zu uns und ihr könnt gerne in der Datenschleuder was veröffentlichen oder auf den Kongressen vortragen. Also ja, wir haben dann Interesse daran. Wir wissen, es gibt ein Problem, aber wir haben zu viele andere Baustellen, um uns da im Moment aktiv darum zu kümmern.
Es gibt denn wenigstens noch einen Tipp, wo man weiter anfassen könnte, das Bundesministerium für Gesundheit wäre jetzt das nächste, weil irgendjemand muss das mal zugelassen haben, das Gerät. Es gibt also in den USA es ist zugelassen, aber es genügt ja nicht für Deutschland. Das heißt, irgendjemand muss sich ja ausreichend damit beschäftigt haben, um zu sagen, dieses Gerät ist sicher für Deutschland.
Ja, das ist so, nein, das ist ein Trittschluss.
Das wird jetzt auch glaube ich ein bisschen zu weit führen. Das kriegen wir sich hier nicht mehr geklärt, weil ich glaube wir wissen es einfach nicht, aber Frilian auf jeden Fall vielen Dank. Dran bleiben und wenn du was rausgefunden hast, sag Bescheid.
Hat bestimmt ein TÜV-Zertifikat.
Das hilft ja richtig viel, hat man schon bei Lübby gesehen. Und auch an der Beispielseite. Okay, jetzt sind wir bei Mail-Servern angekommen und bei Ralf.
Hallo.
Erzähl mal.
Ja, es ist schon zwei Jahre her und da hatte ich ein paar Rechner hier und ich hatte ein paar Netzwerkprobleme und hat mal ein bisschen gescannt in meinem privaten Netzwerk, also hinter dem Router mit dem Lisa-Demon, falls ihr jemand kennt, Linux und jedenfalls tauchten auf einmal ein paar NFS-Freigaben auf, die nicht in meinem Subnet waren.
Okay, warte Ralf, also ja, das ist das Chaosradio, aber es wäre schick, wenn du es so erklärst, dass es auch die Leute verstehen, die sozusagen einfach das Interessant finden und nicht genau wissen, was eine NSF-Freigabe war, blabla.
Okay, das wollte ich jetzt gleich machen. Also es war ein Programmchen, mit dem man feststellen kann, welche Rechner dann noch im Netz sind und was die denn so an Freigaben haben. Und da tauchten dann jedenfalls, wie unter Windows, so ein paar Ordner auf, die ich überhaupt nicht kannte, überhaupt nicht einordnen konnte und die sahen mir sehr nach einem Unix-Server aus und dann habe ich da mal ein bisschen reingeguckt und dann dachte ich, ups, das sieht ja aus wie ein Mailserver und habe ich dann da nochmal reingeguckt und dann habe ich da nochmal reingeguckt und dann habe ich ein bisschen geschluckt und dann sah ich da ganz viele Usernamen von dem Provider, bei dem ich auch bin. Und dann habe ich da ganz reingeguckt und dann habe ich festgestellt, ich konnte ganz viele Mails lesen, von Tausenden von Leuten. Ja vielleicht.
Was kommt dazu?
Ich habe ja nichts geknackt oder so. Also ich habe da einfach nur reingeguckt.
Das ist trotzdem ausspielen von Daten.
Ja, das war dann auch meine erste Reaktion.
Das hängt auf den Richter, kommt auf den Richter an, ob der sagt, das sei geschnitzt gewesen. In solchen Fällen zu uns kommen.
Naiv, wie ich bin, habe ich dann meinen Provider angerufen, soll heißen die Hotline. Die Dame meinte dann, ob ich irgendwie Windows schon mal noch installiert hatte oder so ähnlich. Jedenfalls meinte, ich müsste dann wohl meinen Techniker sprechen. Und ja, was für ein Problem haben Sie denn? Und ich meinte dann, nee, das Problem haben Sie. Und ich müsste jetzt wirklich mal ganz dringend mit dem Techniker sprechen. Und dann habe ich jemanden bekommen, der meinte, er wäre zwar kein Techniker, die wären gerade alle in einer Versammlung, aber er hätte doch einen ziemlichen Durchblick. Und dann habe ich dem das erzählt. Und dann meinte er, ja, was sehen Sie denn da? Und dann habe ich ihm die Ordnerstruktur mal genannt, meinte er, ob Sie sehen das ja wirklich? Und dann habe ich ihm auch noch, bin ich dann in die Ordner reingegangen mit ihm und habe ihm dann auch noch irgendwelche Mailheader vorgelesen und dann meinte er, ja, da müssen wir wohl was machen. Und dann hat er versprochen, er wollte sich mit den Technikern, sobald die wieder verfügbar sind, unterhalten. Und die haben mich dann nach vier Stunden angerufen. Ich habe also mehrmals geguckt, ob ich noch dran bin. Reicht dann auch. Und dann war es weg.
Na, siehst du, ist doch zu Glück gehabt.
Ja, fand ich gut. Ich habe dann auch mal kurz mit Heise gesprochen, weil das ist immer so meine Idee, wo ich anrufe. Die hatten da auch einen kurzen Artikel in Heise Security drüber gebracht und wo mir dann ein bisschen schwindlig geworden ist, als ich die Kommentare gelesen habe, weil da nämlich genau das gesagt worden ist. Da kannst du aber ganz schön Ärger kriegen.
Auf jeden Fall. Also ich meine, dass es sozusagen irgendwie da schon reingeguckt zu haben, jetzt, also selbst ich ohne großes Fach, das würde sagen, uiuiui.
Ja, ja, ich habe ja auch sofort gedacht, ich könnte jetzt wahnsinnig Schindluder mit treiben. Da waren ja auch E-Mails von Ebay, also mit Ebay-Usern oder Paypal oder so. Ja, ich habe mein Passwort vergessen und schick mir das doch mal bitte zu oder so. Hätte ich ja rein theoretisch machen können. Und rein theoretisch, so wie ich es dann nachher verstanden habe, hätte da jeder Kunde dieses Telekom-Anbieters hätte das rein theoretisch auch machen können und ich weiß nicht, wie viel es schon gemacht haben.
Hast du denn von der Firma irgendwas gehört?
Ja, einen Tag später haben die sich bei mir bedankt und mich gefragt, was ich denn haben möchte, eins von ihren Werbegeschenken und die haben mir dann einen Monat die Telefongebühren entlassen.
Das ist doch eine Win-Win-Situation.
Ja, bei Heise stand dann auch drin, vielleicht kriegt ihr ja ein T-Shirt, wo drin steht, I owned Dingens und I got all this lousy T-Shirt.
Nicht schlecht, okay. Und das war es dann aber?
Das war es dann aber, aber ich fand das dann schon heftig.
Bist du noch bei demselben Betreiber?
Ich bin immer noch zufriedener Kunde.
Ja, ist doch toll, wenn man den Melder selber warten kann im Notfall.
Ja, finde ich auch. Wir haben mir dann auch gesagt, das wäre nur ein System für die Migration gewesen und eigentlich war das gar nicht da.
In Wirklichkeit alles gar kein Problem.
Alles klar.
Sehr schön. Ralf, vielen Dank für die Geschichte. So, und dann haben wir noch jemand, der sich Psypointer nennt. Hallo, guten Abend. Was ist deine Story?
Ich hab mich gegen Full-Disclosure entschieden, nachdem ich ein paar schlechte Erfahrungen gemacht hab. Ich hab im Jahr 2004 durch Zufall von einem CDU-Kreistags-Server ein paar Passwörter rausbekommen. Also ich hatte eigentlich ein paar andere Dinge gesucht und hatte plötzlich hohen Zugriff. Und ich hab dann den Host da angeschrieben, dass ich da eben Zugriff hab und wo die Sicherheitslücke ist und gleichzeitig dann als junger Mensch die Dummheit gemacht und einen kleinen Atomwaffentest in dem CDU-Technikkalender angekündigt. Ich hab mir dabei nicht weitergedacht, bis ich dann halt am nächsten Morgen in der Zeitung plötzlich einen Artikel Ärger mit Hacker und Lass und das Ganze hat dann ziemlich Wellen geschlagen und die CDU hat dann auch eine Strafanzeige gemacht und so weiter und so fort. Ich bin dann nochmal mit einem blauen Auge rausgekommen. Das war für mich eigentlich eine recht lehrreiche Situation, weil da hab ich mir geschworen, beim nächsten Mal sehr vorsichtig zu sein. Und seitdem fahr ich eigentlich immer sehr gut damit, wenn ich irgendwas finde, zum Beispiel beim T-Konzern hab ich mal was gefunden, wo es wirklich auch um User-Daten ging, die Leute wirklich nur privat anzuschreiben. Ich krieg dann auch meistens recht schnell die richtigen Leute ans Telefon oder per Mail und denen das zu reporten, damit gar nicht in die Öffentlichkeit zu gehen. So Leute wie der T-Konzern, die reagieren da eigentlich recht freundlich, aber sonst auch nicht. Inzwischen hab ich einen Job bei den Jungs, aber das ist was anderes. Hängt das zusammen? Ich denke wahrscheinlich ja. Also das ist ein anderer Jobsektor, aber sie kennen meinen Namen inzwischen eigentlich recht gut, weil ich hatte öfter mit ihm zu tun. Und die schönste Aktion, die ich mal hatte, war, dass ich einen kleinen Host, einen mit so großem Host dafür solche kostenlosen Seiten hatte. Also so typisch, dass man kann sich 25 Megabyte Webspace machen, eine MySQL-Data, und dann kriegt man, und das ist werbefinanziert. Also wo zig Kitties ihre Seiten hosten. Und da gab es einen ziemlich bösen Fehler mit MySQL und PHP, dass man halt mit MySQL-User rumlaufen konnte und einfach Daten aus dem Dateilsystem in seine Datenbank laden konnte als MySQL-User. Und dann fröhlich dort von jedem User die Dateien lesen konnte. Das heißt, man konnte sich von jedem User, der da irgendwelche PHP-Config-Dateien hatte oder so, einfach auch die Passwörter ziehen und alles. Und ich habe den Jungs dann einen Demo-Exploit geschrieben, wie man das dann wirklich einfach über einen Web-Script auch benutzen konnte, also mit Fahrtangaben einfach rein und dann konnte man direkt die Daten sehen. Und dann kam ein paar Tage eine Meldung, ja, wir schätzen das sehr, wir würden gerne Ihre Adresse haben. Ich habe jetzt überlegt und habe aber gesagt, ich habe jetzt nichts da reingeschrieben, von wegen irgendwie ich will Geld haben oder sowas. Hab denen auch die Adresse gegeben und da kam später ein Kasten schön mit Champagner und irgendwelchen Süßigkeiten da drin, die aus der Gegenbrücke kamen und dann gibt es Brief. Die haben auch gefragt, ob ich einen Job haben will und seitdem fahre ich eigentlich immer so, dass ich den Leuten eine Mail schreibe, was genau los ist. Überhaupt keine Forderung, das ist einfach nur, schreibe ich rein, das war jetzt eine kostenlose Info, das ist mir aufgefallen. Und wenn sie Interesse haben an weiteren Dienstleistungen, dann können sie mich gerne anschreiben, dann kriegen sie die Infos oder kriegen sie noch mehr Infos.
Das reicht aber schon um die Bestellung, um dir zu unterstellen, dass du die erpressen willst. Also du kannst auch echt Glück mit haben, das scheint bisher so gelaufen zu sein, aber schon die Andeutung, dass du für weitere Dienstleistungen zur Verfügung stehst, wird von manchen Leuten als Erpressung ausgelegt.
Ja, aber dann hab ich also mit...
Ja, gut, also dann freu dich aber ab jetzt vorsichtig.
Ich hab es darauf geachtet, also sehr, sehr vorsichtig formuliert, nie irgendwie gesagt, ich hab noch Daten oder so und ich könnte, aber ich hab gesagt, ich bin in einem Sektor tätig und wenn ihr Interesse habt, könnt ihr meine Dienstleistungen haben und das war's auch. Und damit hab ich eigentlich sehr gute Erfahrungen gemacht, wie hab ich mit dem Full Disclosure oder in solchen Aktionen irgendwas in die Öffentlichkeit bringen, die ich schlechte Erfahrungen gehabt hab, weil die Leute dann sofort zum Anwalt rennen und Schafanzeige erstatten und sonst jeden Tag machen.
Würdest du das sagen, nach dem, was du heute gehört hast, genauso handhaben in Zukunft?
Ja, es gibt eine einzige Ausnahme. Ich würde nur ein Full Disclosure bei Dingen machen, die wirklich viele Leute betreffen, weil Menschenleben bedrohen oder wichtige Daten bedrohen. Wenn jetzt zum Beispiel Thema Gesundheitskarte, hab ich mal ein paar Dinge über viele Ecken gehört, was da wohl so an der Sicherheitsprogrammierung für Leute gearbeitet haben und was da teilweise für Vorgehensweise waren. Und wenn ich da jetzt irgendwie was Konkretes hätte, das würde ich natürlich sofort publishen. Weil ich finde sowas gehört in die Öffentlichkeit, das betrifft uns alle. Aber so diese kleinen Sachen, die der Hostel, der entsprechende Anbieter auch sofort fixt, die würde ich weiterhin geschlossen halten. Weil das am wenigsten Ärger bringt und persönlich die meisten Chancen eigentlich mitgebracht.
Du würdest es auch nach wie vor direkt machen?
Ich würde es auch nach wie vor direkt machen, nur eben sehr, sehr vorsichtig formuliert, ganz klar, dass da nicht irgendwer kommen kann und sagen kann, ja, hier, der will uns erfressen oder sonstiges, sondern wirklich einfach nur, ich hab was gefunden durch Zufall wirklich, nur direkt rumgucken, ich vermute, dass da weitere Sachen sind, gucken sie mal da und da, also, nicht sehr weit daraus halten, weil sonst ist es zu heiß.
Vielen Dank für deine Geschichte, die auch die letzte war heute im Chaosradio, im letzten Chaosradio im Jahr. Wolltest du noch ein berühmtes letztes Wort sprechen oder wolltest du noch ein bisschen Werbung machen?
Genau, für den Kongress müssen wir noch Werbung machen, weil das nämlich das letzte Chaosradio vom Kongress ist.
Mir fällt wieder noch kurz ein, was er eben berichtet hat, das ist natürlich richtig bei so ISPs und Unternehmen, die mit Internet viel zu tun haben. Es gibt aber auch Unternehmen, für die ist Internet ja eher eine Infrastruktur, die machen was ganz anderes und die haben teilweise ganz andere Sicherheitskulturen bis hin zu eigentlich die Sicherheitsverantwortlichen, die nur so eine Scheinfunktion haben, die nur eingesetzt werden, um gefeuert zu werden, wenn etwas passiert, um den Ruf zu wahren, dass das ein sicheres Unternehmen sei. Aber in der Tat werden wir über diese und andere Themen zwischen dem 27. und 30. Dezember sehr viel diskutieren im Rahmen des 26. 26C3.
Also zwischen den Jahren, nämlich von 27. bis 30.
Dezember.
Dezember gibt es den Chaos-Kongress, der 26. Und der findet statt im?
BCC, das ist der Kongresszentrum Alexanderplatz.
Und da wird es wahrscheinlich wieder voll. Das heißt, wenn ihr nicht aus Berlin seid und euch denkt, ich hab hier ein paar Kumpels und mit denen zusammen kann ich mir auch einen schönen Kellerraum mit dem Beamer holen und dann gucken wir uns gemeinsam die Streams an, dann googelt mal nach Dragons Everywhere. Da haben wir mich diesmal ein Programm für vorgesehen.
Man darf aber schon auch vorbeikommen.
Man darf gerne vorbeikommen, freuen wir uns auch drüber. Aber wenn euch das eh schon zu voll war die letzten Jahre und ihr eigentlich im Grunde nur die Streams und mit ein paar Kumpels Hackcenter simulieren wollt, dann haben wir auch dafür was vorgesehen. Aber ihr seid alle herzlich eingeladen.
Wird es W-Lang geben dieses Jahr?
Natürlich, ob das funktioniert, ist die Frage.
Alles klar, dann vielen Dank euch. Viel Spaß euch da draußen, wenn ihr die ganze Sendung nochmal hören wollt, um all die kleinen Anspielungen und Scherze nochmal nachzuvollziehen. Oder einfach nochmal ganz genau, wie das ist mit dem Responsible Disclosure. Das Ganze gibt es auch als Podcast, wahrscheinlich jetzt gleich irgendwo im Netz. Morgen auf jeden Fall auch hochoffiziell auf ritz.de. Ansonsten alle Infos und Links zur Sendung gibt es bei chaosradio.de. Und damit sind wir raus übergeben an Maxwell Smart, der euch im Night Flight gleich mit Pussikbeer werfen wird, bis eure Ohren bluten. Und dann sage ich mal Tschüss und bis zum nächsten Jahr.
Schönen Abend noch.